good old Mississippi it's everything I
remember it being from every other movie
that takes place in Mississippi the help
so the help starts emmastone it takes
place in Mississippi a place made famous
by Mark Twain and blatant racism and
Emma Stone she's a writer and she's not
like the other you know uppity chicks of
Mississippi namely Bryce Dallas Howard
which is funny cuz you think yourself
the Battle of the Gwen Stacy's Emma
Stone sees how house maids are treated
down there and Emma Stone's like
[ __ ] they don't get treated like
people it's totally true I mean they get
paid like a hundred bucks a month to
cook and clean after white people which
sucks because I mean we're really sloppy
people we're messy we're needy I would
never take that job like ever in a
million years and it's not just one of
those work sucks kind of scenarios I
mean they're actually abused they're
mentally abused their belittled they
have to use different bathrooms so
you're like I like the depiction of the
60s better in x-men first class and no
one ever does anything about it or says
anything about it because it's actually
illegal to print anything that says
white people and black people are
actually equals and so emma stones like
you know what their story should be
published and told i'm gonna write about
them so people know I mean after all as
a wise man once said we must all make
the choice between what is right and
what is easy Albus Dumbledore and
probably a few other people who were
actually real it's gonna make her a lot
of enemies yeah but it's gonna make her
a few friends too now I really like this
movie I didn't think I would cuz I heard
the movie was just about like some chick
who writes about other chicks and I was
like I'm not gonna relate to this movie
at all but it's really not an accurate
description of the movie I like this
movie because of what I hate and I hate
apathy I hate it when people just sit by
and just watch shitty things happen to
people I mean just take action people
don't take action as much as you think
they probably should so Emma Stone's
like you know what I'm gonna be the
person that takes action and I like that
immediately I'm like alright I'm into
this movie
it's a wool written movie so well acted
movie the characters I really like - cuz
one of the housemaids that Emma Stone
befriends she's really nice she's really
quiet she's the first one that's kind of
like alright I'll tell you my story as
long as you never tell anyone I told you
it is Mississippi in the 60s that's not
exactly paradise and the other one Emma
Stone befriends she is the one she'll
tell you how it is and she can't keep
her mouth shut so she usually gets fired
I liked her she was awesome now although
you can't say this movie is bad at all
cuz you can you can say it is very long
when I was watching this movie I was
like this is like the kind of movie that
high school teachers forced their
high-school students to watch so high
school students call that time naptime
every is a character based literary
period piece it's not gonna appeal to
everybody however I think those people
in time like when they're in their 20s
and whatnot they'll appreciate this
movie you know when they actually have
to think about real world kind of [ __ ] I
mean it's funny because I didn't think
the movie was too long for what it was I
can't think of a part in the movie where
I'm like oh that was that clearly
dragged on they should you just cut that
out so apparently two hours in 20
minutes is what the movie needs to be
doesn't change the fact that it's a two
hour and 20 minute drama and if you're
in high school and your teacher forces
you to watch this and you actually don't
sleep through the class you'll actually
like it so I will say it's a good time
no alcohol required I mean I laughed I
got attached with the characters I you
know didn't cry kind of wanted to that
it's touching in parts I ain't
apologizing so since I have an insane
amount of a DD I'm not gonna jump up to
the opportunity to watch a two and a
half hour drama like every day but I
watched it today and I'm glad I did so
are you gonna see the help have you seen
the help comment below let me know what
you thought about it it's gonna be all
check comments at that point cuz guys if
you didn't know what the help was don't
worry I didn't until like 48 hours ago
in any case if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]